We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centri.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And this is Jeff Mayno. My name is Jeff Mayno. I'm an architecture writer and blogger based in Los Angeles.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、环境和教育领域最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全是该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21centri.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这位是杰夫·迈诺。我叫杰夫·迈诺。我是一名总部设在洛杉矶的建筑作家和博主。
And for seven years, he has written a website called Building Blog, which is about architectural conjecture, urban speculation, and landscape futures. I've always liked the sounds of things and the acoustic nature walking through the city or even just the sense that when you're walking down a hall that has really rich lush wall coverings the right side can sound totally different from the left side. I've just always been interested in those sorts of acoustic aspects of architectural space. Most architects, if they design for sound, what they're actually designing to do is design
七年来，他一直在运营一个名为“建筑博客”的网站，内容涉及建筑推测、城市投机和景观未来。我一直很喜欢事物的声音以及走过城市时的声学质感，甚至只是那种当你走过铺有极其丰富华丽墙面装饰的走廊时，右侧的声音听起来可以和左侧完全不同的感觉。我一直对建筑空间的这类声学方面很感兴趣。大多数建筑师，如果他们为声音进行设计，他们实际在做的设计是
for silence. They're designing to keep sound out of the environments. They're designing to make sure that you don't hear the street sounds that are happening outside or that you're insulated from cars driving by or from the gravel plant up the road. So it's really an architecture of silence that people tend to be designing for. But you know having said that there was an interesting project a couple years ago by an architect named Joel Sanders. It was basically an architectural design. Instead of standard glass windows it would use things like parabolic microphones kind of like those things that you see people
为了安静。他们的设计旨在将声音挡在环境之外。他们的设计旨在确保你听不到外面发生的街道声音，或者让你免受过往车辆或路上碎石厂噪音的影响。因此，人们倾向于设计的其实是寂静的建筑。不过话虽如此，几年前有一位名叫乔尔·桑德斯的建筑师做了一个有趣的项目。它基本上是一个建筑设计。它不使用标准玻璃窗，而是使用抛物面麦克风之类的东西，有点像你在
holding on the sides of the football field during NFL games. These parabolic microphones would be pointed at the sky or they'd be pointed out into the woods nearby or they would capture the sounds of airplanes flying overhead or birds in the forest or, for that matter, kids down the road. It very consciously and clearly brings acoustics into the architectural equation.
NFL比赛期间看到人们拿着站在足球场边上的那种东西。这些抛物面麦克风会指向天空，或者指向附近的树林，或者它们会捕捉头顶飞过的飞机声、森林里的鸟叫声，或者，就此而言，远处孩子们的笑声。它非常刻意且清晰地将声学纳入了建筑方程式中。
There was an article in a British magazine called The Wire. It was an article about generative sound, so to speak. It referred to this idea of a quote unquote sound garden. Rather than being the 1990s grunge band, they were talking actually about the idea that you would deliberately plant certain species of flowering trees and that kind of thing in your back garden, so that you could sort of time an acoustic event over the course of the year. There are certain species that when they bloom the seed pod opens up with an audible pop. It's kind of the acoustic equivalent of the daisies coming up through the ground or the tulips
英国一本名为《电线》的杂志上曾刊登过一篇文章。那是一篇关于生成音乐的文章，可以这么说。它提到了一个名为“声学花园”的概念。它指的不是20世纪90年代的垃圾摇滚乐队，而是实际上探讨这样一种想法：你会在后花园里刻意种植某些种类的开花树木等植物，以便在一年当中按时引发一场声学事件。某些种类的植物在花开时，种子荚会伴随着一声清晰的爆裂声打开。这可以说是雏菊破土而出或郁金香
blooming. There's all kinds of other species that have particularly kind of silky leaves that brush against each other in the breeze so you can fall asleep at night to the sound of this kind of really silky and silvery sort of tree brushing sound. That's one thing I think is really quite interesting that you could actually deliberately sort of build an acoustic ecosystem. You know, you could you could easily imagine that sort of thing being added on to a kind of botanic garden so that you pay money to go literally listen to plant life. Jeff Mayno is also interested in archaeoacoustics. Good question. It's
绽放的声学版本。还有各种各样的其他植物，它们的叶子特别丝滑，在微风中相互擦拂，因此你可以在夜晚伴随着这种丝滑而银铃般的树木摩擦声入眠。这是我认为非常有趣的一点，即你实际上可以刻意构建一个声学生态系统。你知道，你可以很容易地想象这种东西被添加到某种植物园中，这样人们就会付费去亲耳聆听植物的生命。杰夫·迈诺也对考古声学感兴趣。好问题。它
basically the concern with, well two things, not only how would a building have sounded or what would have been the acoustic effect of a certain building when that building was standing, but then also what was the sort of sound culture of a given civilization or village, old Mayan temples were built not just as spectacular mountain-like constructions, but specifically as acoustic devices that would amplify not only the voice of the priest, but also the sounds of things like the quonk shells that would be played to do ritualistic music and that sort of thing. The building was actually
基本上关注两个问题：不仅是当一座建筑竖立时它听起来会是什么样，或者特定建筑会产生什么样的声学效果，还有某个文明或村庄的声学文化是怎样的。古玛雅神庙的建造不仅是为了打造壮观的群山般的建筑，而且专门将其作为声学装置，不仅能放大祭司的声音，还能放大用于演奏仪式音乐的法螺等物品的声音。该建筑实际上被
physically designed to be as echoey as possible. The buildings themselves were like acoustic resonators or subwoofers, so to speak, that were deliberately made to help induce a kind of almost like a psychedelic state in people. That's archaeoacoustics. It's like Indiana Jones meets John Cage. I think architects are too willing to sort of let acoustics and sound be taken care of by sound designers
物理设计得尽可能具有回声。这些建筑本身就像声学共振器或低音炮，可以说是故意用来帮助诱导人们进入一种几乎类似于迷幻状态的感觉。这就是考古声学。这就像是印第安纳琼斯遇到了约翰·凯奇。我认为建筑师太愿意让声学和声音交给音响设计师去处理
or taken up by other people. And I think it really would be interesting to see them think more in terms of how to integrate their building into the soundscape of a city. There's a lot of talk with an architecture of how to build something that's contextually specific and really responds to its site. But the site, quote unquote, is almost always literally a question of site. It's an optical relationship to the city. It would really be interesting, actually, to think about architects going out to sort
或者由其他人来接手。并且我认为，看到他们更多地思考如何将建筑融入城市的声景中，将是一件非常有趣的事情。建筑界有很多关于如何建造具有语境特定性并真正响应其地点的建筑的讨论。但这个所谓的“地点”，几乎字面意思上总是局限于地块本身。它是与城市的视觉关系。实际上，如果能让建筑师走出去
of acoustically map the city block where their building is going to be and then figuring out a nice way to intervene in it and maybe reflect those sounds back at the neighborhood. Too much silence is no more interesting than too much noise. 99% invisible was produced this week by Nick Vanderkulk. I'm your host, Roman Mars. The program is made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architects, San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design.
对其建筑所在的街区进行声学测绘，然后想出一种绝妙的方式介入其中，并可能将这些声音反射回社区，那将非常有趣。过多的安静并不比过多的噪音更有趣。《99%隐形》本周由尼克·范德库尔克制作。我是你的主持人罗曼·马尔斯。本节目是在 Lunar 的支持下制作的，Lunar 致力于用创意带来改变。这是 KALW、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。
To find out more, including links to Jeff Maynows' Building Blog, which is essential reading you should absolutely go there. And Nick Vanderkulk's Love in radio, which is a program he does for voclow.org and it's stunning and brilliant and darkly fascinating. And Nick is one of the sonic innovators in the field, absolutely the best. I was going to include an excerpt actually at the end of this program, but man, that program is for adults I got I have eighth grade kids who listen to this I couldn't do it I just couldn't do it Anyway you should absolutely check it out if you're an adult you will love it
欲了解更多信息，包括杰夫·迈诺的“建筑博客”的链接——这是你绝对应该去阅读的必读内容。还有尼克·范德库尔克的《爱在广播》，这是他为 voclow.org 制作的一个节目，令人惊叹、才华横溢且带有黑暗的迷人色彩。尼克是该领域的声波创新者之一，绝对是最棒的。我原本打算在这个节目的末尾放一段节选，天哪，那个节目是给成年人看的，我这里有上八年级的孩子在听这个，我不能这么做，我就是做不到。无论如何，如果你是成年人，你绝对应该去看看，你会喜欢的
it's at loveandradio.org and you'll find a link to that on 99%invisible.org .org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 loveandradio.org，你可以在 99%invisible.org 上找到该链接。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。